[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the petition to remake Game of
Thrones season a is almost a 1 million
signatures and with the finale right
around the corner that number is bound
to skyrocket we all know that HBO will
never go back and redo the entire season
so the internet have banded together to
do with themselves those who've been
keeping up with this show will know that
there's several glaring issues with the
way that some of the characters have
been handled so many have took to Reddit
to show how things should have been done
throughout this video I'll be putting
together the best fan changes as well as
my own to give you the season 8 that
fans deserved this is full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't seen up to
episode 5 then I highly recommend that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of how to fix the final season
of Game of Thrones ok so two of the
biggest points of criticism with season
8 are the killing of dragon Ragle out of
nowhere by Iran and the bells ringing in
episode 5 which sent Danny off the deep
end
both of these moments felt like huge gut
punches and was shocking for the wrong
reasons with the two feeling very
undeserved ready set to KO 29 has come
up with a way to combine the two to tell
the story differently and in my opinion
way better the user said that ragle
instead should die during the siege of
King's Landing which is the big thing
that pushes Danny over the edge and on
the path to genocide this huge loss for
her ties the two together beautifully
and gives motive to her madness the
redditor was also kind enough to edit
the two scenes together which I'll now
play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
as you can see it's way better and would
have made much more impact than the two
completely breakneck turns that we got
in the actual show this would really
allow for the vendetta between Cersei
and Dany and it's just personal enough
that you can understand why Daenerys
ends up going on a rampage another big
thing that many fans feel that the
creators got wrong is Jamie's Ark with
the character being reduced to a pretty
pussy-whipped brother
reddit user etc edit together some
images which tells us Ark far better
than the one we got
except traces that Jamie should have
knighted Brienne in Episode two and that
the two should have had sex at this
point instead of later in the season
after this Brienne is killed in the
Battle of Winterfell and naturally Jaime
is devastated because this is the only
woman since Cersei that is really cared
about from here Jamie with nowhere else
to turn gold running back to his ex I
mean sister and together the two reunite
whilst this is better
the redditor did still think that Jaime
and Cersei still should get killed by
bricks which I don't really agree with
actually thinking that we should have
got something similar to what was
portrayed in the leaks personally I
think that Jaime should have still went
back to Cersei but had a change of heart
and rang the bells of surrender when he
realized that all was lost this would
have showed that he's no longer Cersei
slave as she would have no doubt have
disapproved of this Jaime's arc is this
complete and he is finally broken free
of his sisters control Cersei goes back
up to the top of the red keep which is
when Danny attacks and the castle
collapses killing Jaime in the process
however this is unbeknownst to Cersei
and later she comes across Jaime
seemingly alive and well Jaime goes to
hug her but at the last moment stabs her
and pulls back his face to reveal that
it is in fact area and that she has
returned to fulfill the prophecy of
killing the one with green eyes as the
red woman promised this would make so
much more sense and also be a fulfilling
info area who has been after the
character since season one Cersei would
get the big twist send-off instead of
the falling rocks that we got and
overall I just feel like area killing
here would be a lot better in addition
to this I kind of wanted to discover in
season eight that bran was indeed the
night king all along well it's this
theory
was pretty played out it only became so
popular because it made so much sense we
could have discovered that the night
king was a future version of bran that
upon reaching an age gained the ability
to time travel and went back to the
children of the forest and was turned
into the undead the night king has been
attempting to kill bran this entire time
so that he could stop himself from going
back and living this life of endless
pain and misery that too for me would
add a lot more to the characters motives
and I would have loved to have seen it
obviously I know this is all wishful
thinking and something that we'll never
get but it would have been amazing to
have played out that way I'd of course
loved hear your thoughts on these
changes and if you prefer them or still
enjoy what we got comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my video of all of the Game of
Thrones actors being disappointed at how
seasoned they turned out which will be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you